cypress a testing solution for web
applications famous for making
test-driven development fun for
javascript developers we all know
testing is the right thing to do but
actually doing it in a front-end
javascript project can be complicated
slow and just not fun for many the
obvious solution is to simply not test
anything at all that's not ideal cyprus
provides an open source browser-based
test runner that can experience your
website just like the end user would it
might fill out a login form click the
submit button then navigate to the user
dashboard all of which happens
programmatically based on code you
define every test is recorded and a
snapshot is saved at each step this
makes it possible to time travel through
the user experience to figure out
precisely why your code sucks and unlike
traditional testing utilities debugging
can be performed directly from the
browser dev tools not only does it work
for end-to-end testing of an entire
application but it's also great for
integration testing and unit testing of
isolated components or javascript
business logic to get started install it
into your project then run npx cypress
open notice how this pulls up the test
runner automatically and creates a
folder in the root of your project named
cypress that contains all of your
testing code fixtures is where you would
define mock data plugins allow you to
hook into the testing life cycle support
is for your global configuration then
your main testing code lives in the
integration file we can create a test
suite with describe then before each
test we can run some setup code like
tell cyprus to visit a specific url from
there use it to describe a test case
where you might verify that the web page
contains a certain piece of content the
get method will grab an element from the
dom and allow you to run assertions on
it like it should have the text to log
in it bundles the chai assertion library
for behavior-driven development which
will autocomplete with intellisense from
there you may want to find a form input
and type something into it after the
form is filled out submit it to update
your database the great thing about
cypress is that it will automatically
wait for async events which means you
don't need to add a bunch of sleepers in
your test code things just work
naturally now run your tests to watch
everything go down visually a snapshot
of the dom is taken for every event if
an assertion fails you can easily
inspect the dom to see what went wrong
on top of that you can open the selector
playground to easily grab any element on
the page by default it runs in chrome
but you can also run in firefox edge or
electron for desktop apps this has been
cypress in 100 seconds hit the like
button and subscribe if you want to see
more short videos like this and if you
want to learn more about testing my
friend bartow's just launched a free
end-to-end testing course thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one